if
if we do not see each other again
we will
we will see each other again
hey guys pete here today i'll be talking
about four old mankind season three
episode seven the one that will be
remembered as pj's first and probably
last episode danny is not doing himself
any favors and neither is larry things
are starting to feel like they're moving
towards the end and the title bring it
down could refer to a few different
things that happened or are in the
process of happening i'll get into all
of that right after i warn you about
spoilers if you haven't watched episode
7 yet then this video won't be for you
and with that out of the way let's get
into it
the joint mission to go discover liquid
water between helios and the soviets is
coming together they leave happy valley
base and kelly secretly blows a kiss to
alexi on his way out at mission control
elena looks relieved to finally have
them leave her space but there isn't any
indication she'll be backing down from
her investigation into the stolen engine
plans the worst revelation in all of
this comes when sergey goes to say
goodbye to margot she's expecting him to
move over to helios's mission command
with the others but he explains that
he's being sent back to moscow
immediately this will make her plan to
rescue him and his family impossible and
for all her efforts this trip to the u.s
will end up being a temporary reprieve
from his incarceration rather than his
path to freedom it takes her time to
work through all the options in her head
and realize there's nothing she can do
and after their devastating goodbye she
breaks down crying into her couch
cushion so no one will hear it's a great
visual representation of her situation
and a reminder that her choices have
brought her to a place where she's truly
alone there's an underlying sense of
futility when she stops him from saying
what he wanted to say in case they never
see each other again by saying they will
everyone understands that won't happen
but what else do you do when someone you
love is being taken away towards a
horrible fate it seems like most fans
have turned against margot and want to
see her get what she has coming but i
still find her sympathetic and the
performances here really made this scene
hit hard for me in another difficult
situation first gentleman larry is being
interviewed in a house subcommittee
hearing on nasa contracts the
implication is that he's using his
influence to hand out contracts to
private firms that he favors and he
seems to be doing a pretty good job of
defending himself right up until things
turn to questions about an affair this
was set up at the end of the last
episode and we see him bring in the aid
in question to ask who he's been talking
to given the power dynamics in play it's
pretty brutal to watch this aide realize
what's going to happen to his life as a
result but it works to show us the lanes
larry might go to to try to fight
against these totally true accusations
understandably ellen tears into him when
she finds out she wants to know why he
couldn't keep it in his pants for even
one term and what's so special about
this aid that he would jeopardize
everything they worked for they have an
intense exchange where larry pleads his
case that all ends up being overshadowed
when he mentions pam's name when they're
talking about making sacrifices because
ellen believed her cover story when she
left she was under the impression that
pam left her to go back to her partner
she's shocked to find out that she
really left so that ellen can move
forward with her career she also feels
betrayed that larry didn't tell her the
truth and that makes you wonder what
will happen when news of his affair
starts getting out they bring in a karl
rove type who's telling a story about
lee atwater on his way in just to remind
you how nasty this politics business is
and he suggests they need to go after
the person who brought the questions up
because he's already had a sex scandal
and he believes that he has more
skeletons in his closet there's a moment
when he says their best defense is their
picture-perfect marriage and even though
ellen and larry know this is all an
elaborate lie they also understand that
he's right apparently it doesn't sit
right with ellen though and after she
leaves we see her clear her schedule to
make a low-key trip to see pam she
arrives at her front door and asks to
come in but we'll have to wait until
next week to see what happens when they
talk
i mentioned before that i wasn't really
sure about this jimmy storyline and it
picks back up in this episode where we
see he's living at danny's place with
his wife and later we'll see her tell
her husband in a call that she's worried
about him part of that is his new
friends which i don't know what to call
them maybe nasa and on or something like
that and we see that they're trying to
use his connections for something they
have planned it seems like he's set up
to fall for the attention that they give
him and it doesn't seem likely that it's
sincere sonny goes with him to jsc to
try to get a hold of a badge and the
whole thing makes you feel bad for
what's happening it's clear she's trying
to make him complicit and he's running
into all of these people who know his
parents and are happy to see him in the
end he grabs rossi's badge after he
shows him this great tribute to his mom
and that first letter she got during
training that changed her life and it
all just kind of makes you feel dirty
rossi's the guy who gave tracy another
chance at jamestown when she was really
messing up and giving him a lot of
problems so the history there it's all
just uh
later at home all of this makes jimmy
feel some remorse and he decides to call
sonny and try to talk her into taking
the badge back he finds out that they've
already used it when they show up at his
house with the statues of his parents
initially he seems relieved and almost
thinks it's funny but it makes you
wonder if there's more to the plan that
he doesn't know about having this in his
possession could implicate him in
something much worse and i think there's
a good chance they're setting him up on
mars the team that did the right thing
and went and saved the soviets and then
got there first are looking pretty
bummed out the astronauts at happy
valley base are dealing with the fallout
from will's announcement and being left
out of this secret mission on the bright
side at least they have a lot more room
to work with and it looks like they may
have fixed some of the problems because
they're not all sitting around sweating
kelly has a call with alexei who tips
her off that they're getting ready to
start drilling she gets upset because
she hasn't finished her tests on the
core sample and she talks to ed to try
to get him to wait until she's done with
her work he just shrugs it off saying
they've done everything they're required
to do and stresses the fact that nasa is
the one who came up with these rules
over at helios base danny is continuing
to pop pills and it's starting to become
clear that there's something wrong with
him ed has to call his name several
times in front of the group during a
meeting while he is just sort of staring
at lights blinking on the wall when he
walks into him spacing out after a call
with his wife he gives a look to show
that he knows there's something going on
but he doesn't do anything about it a
little later just to really drive the
point home danny flips out and stomps a
robotic toy dog to death in front of
everyone and while this was a little bit
goofy it's a great choice to show how
unhinged he is of course this thing is
annoying him but come on it looks like
an adorable puppy this earns him a
talking to from ed where he takes him
off the flight to the drilling site he
also calls him out for taking drugs but
still doesn't go any further he just
assigns him to help out nick on
communication and then danny acts up and
looks like he wants to hit him and
instead of confining him to quarters or
sending him back to polaris ed just
punks him out and leaves it at that
back on earth elena meets with her
husband and we learn that they're
separated the implication is that over
the last couple of years that we skipped
ahead those problems we heard them
discussing about her always being at
work and everything else with her father
finally caught up to them as part of her
investigation she asked him to help her
look at the list of people who had
access to the plans that the soviets got
their hands on after we get the
impression that elena is hoping that
they might be able to get back together
and that her father's situation is
getting worse her husband brings up that
it might not be someone that works for
her implying that it could be someone
above her that is compromised later she
goes into margot's office and it seems
like she's going to accuse her but
instead she thinks it's her assistant
emma margot laughs this off because it's
actually pretty funny but the reality is
that elena went there because she hasn't
been able to believe that margot could
be the one who's working with the
soviets and as someone who hasn't
completely turned my back on margot this
is truly horrifying watching her
gaslight elena and get to the point of
threatening her i mean i know her career
is on the line and it's the logical path
for her to take but there's no excusing
it if the shoe were on the other foot
she'd be doing the exact same thing
elena is and so when we see her go out
into the lobby and finally have the
realization as she's looking at margot's
picture there's a satisfaction but it's
all just tragic the drilling operation
is on the way and out on the ridge the
soviet commander asked the question i
wonder what this valley will look like
in 10 20 or 100 years and he probably
should have thought more in the scale of
20 minutes but we'll get to that they
start drilling and they get ready for
his part back at the hab danny decides
to prep with a handful of pills they're
monitoring the pressure to make sure
that the drilling site doesn't explode
and nick steps away to run some numbers
leaving danny in charge i'm not sure if
it's implied that he's so wasted that he
can't respond or that he's doing it on
purpose to sabotage ed he's definitely
wasted but he also has some flashes of
the confrontation with that but it
doesn't really matter because he doesn't
do his job and things turn catastrophic
it's chaotic and i'm not sure what the
damage will be when the dust settles but
ed and isabel are injured from the drill
in the beginning they bring them back in
the msam and then all hell breaks loose
when the ridge starts to come down danny
is able to get ed to safety and it
looked like the soviet commander who
went ahead to prepare the med bay made
it into the other half beyond that
alexei luiza nick and isabel seem to get
caught in the dust if not the rock slide
that's rolling over the base
at the very least the msam will probably
be lost and it's possible that kelly's
boyfriend and the only person who knew
what danny did to cause the accident
will be somewhere on the scale of
injured to dead and the episode ends
there
so this episode had a really thrilling
ending and the tension is being
ratcheted up across the board i still
haven't really warmed up to the jimmy
storyline and while it was overall a
good episode i think what knocks it down
a little bit for me is that the
characters that i like are making bad
decisions and none of them feel like
they're going to be able to get out
clean you can understand why they're
doing the things they're doing but
they're frustrating ed letting danny
slide so much how can you defend his
decision to put the crew member he knows
is high anywhere near the drilling
operation he's got such a blind spot and
lives may be lost as a result i guess
this is why margot didn't want to test
pilot to be the commander of the mars
mission but i'm hoping to see ed turn
things around because trying to treat
dany like gordo is not the right way to
go i guess things are moving along in
that story and that's a good thing but
if nick dies then no one would know that
he's responsible and where do we go from
there i know margot's been focused on
getting sergey and his family out but
for as smart and in control as she is i
hope she has a better plan than throwing
elena under the bus to save her own skin
it's possible there's no coming back for
her and this downfall will serve a
latest story since she's the one that
would probably be in charge next season
but geez there's a lot hanging over
these two right now and you would kind
of hate to see margot go out like that
there were a couple of character scenes
that stood out margot putting up her
guard emotionally as sergey was saying
goodbye wren schmidt really nailed that
scene i also liked the handheld shots of
the board with tracy's picture when
jimmy was looking at it they haven't
really developed his character much so
it seems smart to lean on him losing his
parents in those scenes since we do have
feelings about them i guess what's most
interesting is that everything sorta
ended on cliffhanger so the next episode
should be a massive one after this crazy
ending i can't wait to see where things
go and i think that's a good place to
leave things let me know in the comments
what you think will happen next and what
you thought about this episode please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon